Der Rasenfunk Kurzpass. Jürgen Kalwa, den ihr alle sehr gut aus dem Rasenfunk kennt, hat ein neues Projekt gestartet. Irgendetwas zwischen klassischem Hörbuch und Podcast. Das allein ist Grund genug, darüber mit ihm zu sprechen. Jetzt hier im Rasenfunk. Ja, einen wunderschönen guten Tag rüber über den großen Teich in wie immer hervorragender Qualität. Du bist einfach ein Profi und das ist auch die perfekte Brücke zu deinem Projekt. Du hast selbst formuliert, ein neues Format, irgendwo zwischen klassischem Hörbuch und Podcast. Wir nennen es Sonics Stories. Das ist auch die Webseite, auf der man alle Informationen dazu bekommt. Und es handelt sich jetzt hier mal nicht um ein Fußballthema. Das muss ich vielleicht als Warnung an die Hörerinnen und Hörer vorausschicken. Ihr kennt das ja schon, wenn mir Gäste oder Themen besonders am Herzen liegen, dann öffne ich auch mal diesen Fußballbezug. Und erweitere den Blick. Und heute sprechen wir über Lance Armstrong, Jürgen. Es ist mehr als selbstverständlich, wenn man sich ein bisschen mehr damit auseinandersetzt, was denn du da getan hast. Und ich glaube, wir haben ja auch damals im FIFA-Prozess schon, das war im Juli letzten Jahres, darauf hingewiesen. Das heißt, vielleicht haben sogar die Hörerinnen und Hörer schon drauf gewartet. Erklär uns doch mal kurz, was hast denn du zu Lance Armstrong gemacht? Und was ist das Besondere an diesem neuen Format?
Naja, wenn ich es ein bisschen ironisch sage, ich bin ja der Typ mit den dreckigen Themen. Ich mache ja Korruption und Gesundheitsprobleme im Sport und Doping. Und im Fall von Lance Armstrong hat sich das halt über viele, viele Jahre ergeben. Für mich als jemand, der aus New York berichtet. Und weil das Thema auch sehr lange gelaufen ist. Also der Mann hat ja über Jahre erstens erfolgreich abstreiten können, irgendetwas gemacht zu haben. Dann gab es den erfolgreichen Versuch über Zeugenaussagen, vereidigte Zeugenaussagen, eine Beweissstruktur hinzubekommen, die für die Anti-Doping-Leute in den USA ausreichend war, um Armstrong zu sperren. Und dann gab es noch viele, viele Jahre, die damit zugebracht wurden, dass die amerikanische Post als Hauptsponsor in der großen Zeit von Armstrong, in der erfolgreichen Zeit ihr Geld wieder haben wollte und sich bei Armstrong auch bedienen wollte, weil der ist ja nun auch sehr reich geworden. Also wir schätzen, der hat so bestimmt 200 Millionen brutto verdient im Laufe seiner Karriere. Und das zog sich dann sehr, sehr lange hin, weil da wurde mit allen möglichen formal-juristischen Elementen gearbeitet und der Richter war auch sehr langmütig. Und im letzten Jahr erst wurde das dann entschieden und nachdem eine Zahl herumgeisterte, dass er möglicherweise, also Armstrong, dass er möglicherweise 100.000, äh, Entschuldigung, das wäre sehr wenig, 100 Millionen Dollar Schadenersatz leisten müsste, weil das amerikanische Recht das theoretisch zumindest zulässt, kam halt eine Einigung zustande, kurz bevor eine Jury einberufen worden wäre, geschworene, und da hat er dann ein paar Millionen bezahlen müssen und kam halt relativ günstig davon und jetzt erst ist dieser Fall, wenn man so will, komplett abgearbeitet und mein Beitrag dazu ist jetzt wirklich diese Geschichte so weit abzubilden, wie sie halt zwischendurch nicht abbildbar war, weil wir eben immer in diesen einzelnen Phasen waren. Jetzt wissen wir eigentlich alles und können es auch darstellen.
Genau und um kurz alle mit ins Boot zu holen, ist ja immerhin hier eigentlich ein Fußballpodcast. Also Lance Armstrong ist der Fahrradfahrer der, na Fahrrad ist schon eine schöne Beschreibung. Da sieht man, da sieht man, warum ich ein Fußballpodcast mache. Er hat die Tour de France gewonnen und zwar siebenmal. Das war rund um die Jahrtausendwende. Ihr erinnert euch vielleicht noch, wenn ihr es damals mitbekommen habt, an die großen Duelle, unter anderem auch mit Jan Ulrich und der hat 99, 2000, 2001, 2002, 2003, 2004, 2005 die Tour de France gewonnen, auch im olympischen Zeitfahren Bronze geholt, im Jahr 2000 und all diese Erfolge kamen eben unter systematischem Doping zustande, was jetzt dann eben jetzt abschließend beurteilt werden kann. Jetzt habe ich schon ein bisschen angekündigt, dass ja auch die Form etwas Besonderes ist bei diesem Projekt. Es gibt das aber auch in zweierlei maß und das Bekannte davon ist, es gibt das ganze als Buch. Nichts als die Wahrheit der Fall Lance Armstrong und die Aufarbeitung des größten Betrugs, Skandals in der Geschichte des Sports hast du es genannt. Wie lief denn die Arbeit an diesem Mammutprojekt ab?
Man könnte fast sagen, dass die abschließende Arbeit, obwohl das auch nicht gerade wenig ist, war fast noch das geringste Problem, sondern im Laufe der Jahre war ich viel unterwegs und habe viele sehr, sehr wichtige Menschen gesprochen, ausführlich interviewt. Dazu gehört zuallererst mal der Journalistenkollege, der wirklich den Armstrong-Fall am stärksten mit angeschoben hat. Der heißt David Walsh. Das ist ein Journalist aus Irland, der aber für die britische Sunday Times arbeitet und der im Radsport und im Golf und noch ein paar anderen Sportarten zu Hause ist. Ich habe auch gesprochen mit Menschen, die wirklich ganz nah dran waren, also zum Beispiel mit einem ehemaligen Teamkollegen, Frankie Andreu und seiner Frau Betsy Andreu, die ihrem Mann sehr viel Druck gemacht hat, als sie mitgekriegt hat, dass er dobt. Und der war dann schon so ein bisschen eh in der Phase, wo seine Karriere ausklingen lassen wollte. Er hat dann aufgehört und war auch irgendwann zusammen mit Betsy bereit, darüber zu reden, was sie erlebt haben. Also wie da auch verbotene Substanzen rumgereicht wurden. Und dann habe ich auch mit zwei sehr wichtigen Kronzeugen sprechen können. Nämlich in der Reihenfolge war das zuerst Tyler Hamilton, der hatte den Buch geschrieben, 2012. Den konnte ich besuchen in Montana, wo er damals lebte. Und wir haben uns stundenlang unterhalten. Und etwas später dann, sagen wir für die Chronologie des Falles, falsch rum, aber für mich eben beides egal. Mit Floyd Landis, der ist nun als ehemaliger Tour de France-Gewinner und dann gedobt und gesperrt. Der ist der wichtigste Baustein, oder sagen wir mal, der Stein, der dann ins Rollen kommt, der die Lawine ins Rollen bringt, weil der nun 2010 auspackt als Erster aus dem inneren Zirkel und zwar sehr genau alles verrät und erklärt. Und Tyler Hamilton rückt dann nach, erzählt eben auch, was er weiß. Und durch diese Gespräche mit diesen Leuten habe ich natürlich auch noch mal einen sehr viel griffigeren und sehr viel abgehangeneren Eindruck bekommen von dem, was in der Armstrong-Welt los war. Und natürlich klaut dann immer auch die Frage auf, hast du auch mit Armstrong gesprochen? Nein, mit ihm habe ich nicht gesprochen. Und das liegt daran, dass er sich einfach auf meine E-Mails nicht meldet. Und ich habe halt aus seinem Umfeld erfahren, ja, also Armstrong macht mit, wenn er das Gefühl hat, er hat was davon. Das konnte ich jetzt auch nicht versprechen, dass er da was von hätte, wenn ich jetzt über ihn schreibe. Aber ich binde noch kurz ab. Ich habe dann eben einen riesigen Vorrat an Interviewmaterial gehabt. Und das ist gut aufgenommenes Interviewmaterial. Und dann habe ich für mich das Gefühl entwickelt, wenn ich das jetzt nicht nutze in einem vernünftigen Maße oder auf eine vernünftige Art und Weise, dann verschenke ich was. Und dadurch komme ich dann an mein Konzept. Wie geht man mit einem klassischen Sachbuchthema um? Die meisten Leute würden einfach ein Manuskript schreiben. Das Buch würde gedruckt, hoffentlich. Und wenn es dann um eine Hörbuchversion ginge, dann würde man einen Sprecher anheuern. Und ein Hörbuchverlag würde sich darum kümmern, das alles aufzunehmen und zu produzieren. Und dann würde man einfach nur dieser Stimme lauschen. Das sind ja oft Schauspieler. Und das ist dann ordentlich aufgenommen. Das ist sicherlich auch alles wunderbar. Aber all diese Bausteine, die eben ich mitgebracht habe, die würden dann unter den Tisch fallen. Und das hätte ich eben schade gefunden. Sagt ich ja schon. Also habe ich mir versucht, etwas zu überlegen. Das klingt dann am Ende, ich würde mal tippen, wie ein Radio-Feature. Aber eben es ist, weil das Buch ja auch sehr lang ist, es sind halt fast sechs Stunden Radio-Feature.
Und daher so ein bisschen die Kombination. Wir können mal reinhören, wie sich das Ganze anhört. Du hast einen Trailer mitgebracht. Hören wir doch mal rein in Nichts als die Wahrheit, der Fall Lance Armstrong von Jürgen.
Sein Geständnis setzte endlich Ermittlungen in Gang. Lance Armstrong wurde gesperrt. Über die Handlanger und Mittäter und warum so viele davon kamen, weiß die Öffentlichkeit nur wenig. Die Menschen verstehen nicht die Maschine, die es war. Aber wenn sie den Niveau und den Depth der Korruption sehen, es schlägt die Menschen in den Gehirn. Ärzte, Agenten, eine freundende Ehefrau, Mitarbeiter von Sponsorenfirmen, Drogenlieferanten, Funktionäre und Journalisten, die bei der Vertuschung helfen. Dies ist das Buch, das dieses System beschreibt. Nichts als die Wahrheit. Ein Hörbuch über den Fall Lance Armstrong und den größten Betrugsskandal in der Geschichte des Sports.
Ja, da hört man ja schon sehr schnell, Jürgen, dass es, so wie du es beschrieben hast, fast schon eine Radiofeature. Hast du dir damit nicht, indem du erst ein Buch geschrieben hast und dann parallel oder danach das gemacht hast, hast du da nicht zwei Dinge, die doppelte Arbeit gemacht?
Das kann ja sein. Das sollte aber auch nicht die erste Überlegung sein. Also die erste Frage ist wirklich, kriegt man seinen Stoff so gut zusammen?
Das ist bei einem Doping-Buch eine schwierige Formulierung.
Okay, ich hatte jetzt kein Wortspiel geplant. Gut erwischt. Also das Material muss man ja, weil es auch sehr divergierend ist. Und es geht um viele verschiedene Figuren, obwohl es eine zentrale Figur gibt, muss man ja irgendwie sortiert bekommen. Und man muss es so aufschreiben, dass jemand beim Lesen oder beim Zuhören überhaupt erstmal einen Faden findet. Und ich würde dieses Buch, so wie es mir jetzt gelungen ist, würde ich mal als von der Kategorie True Crime sprechen, was ja so im Buchmarkt auch existiert, dass man also wahre Kriminalfälle nacherzählt. Und dazu kommt in meinem Fall, weil ich eben, ja ich bin ja nicht der, der selber auspackt, ich bin ja der, der es zusammenbringt, auch so ein bisschen die Erklärungsansatz, also warum gerade jemand wie ich so was macht, das ist auch ein Faden in dem Buch. Und das Weitere ist einfach wirklich, sich zu überlegen, wie kann so eine Dramaturgie aussehen und welche Fragen, die eben noch ein paar Jahre danach immer noch existieren, nicht geklärt sind, wie kann man damit umgehen. Also es gibt einen Kapitel zum Beispiel über die sogenannte Einzeltätertheorie und das kommt immer wieder hoch, wenn aktuell, wie jetzt aktuell auch im Wintersport, Dopingfälle hochkommen, alle nicht direkt Beteiligten, alle nicht direkt Bezichtigbaren tun immer so, als hätten sie von nichts gewusst, als sei das alles überraschend gewesen, als seien sie auch nicht zuständig, Dinge aufzuklären und als ging es nur darum, eine Absetzbewegung hinzubekommen gegenüber den dann tatsächlich überführten oder geständigen Sportlern, die dann auch alle etwas komisch aus der Wäsche gucken, wenn sie dann erwischt werden oder gestehen. Und das lässt sich eben am Fall Lance Armstrong ganz gut nachzeichnen. Auch da lebte die Dopinkultur im Radsport sehr stark davon, dass man immer so getan hat, es gibt da gar kein System, es gibt da gar keine mafiaartige Beschäftigung mit dem Thema. Und das ist zum Beispiel jetzt ein Kapitel, wo ich das versuche, auch auseinanderzunehmen. Es gibt einen anderen Aspekt, wenn es um Mittäter und Mitwisser geht, zum Beispiel Sponsorenfirmen, die also null Interesse haben, Dinge aufzuklären. Man kann ihnen nicht nachweisen, dass sie was gewusst haben, aber sie wollen auch gar nicht ran an die Geschichte. Also man muss bei Armstrong auf jeden Fall eine Sportausrüst-Firma wie Nike nennen, wie ein Brillenhersteller wie Oakley. Firmen, die, nicht zu vergessen, drei Radhersteller, Track, der sogar sich auf Armstrongs Seite geschlagen hat und versucht hat einen anderen Geschäftspartner, den dreifachen Tour de France-Sieger, Greg LeMond, von seiner Anti-Doping-Haltung abzubringen, weil man befürchtete, das würde das Geschäft verderben. Und dann gab es hinter den Kulissen, wie es sich später rausstellte, klare Versuche von Armstrong mit solchen Leuten wie bei Track Druck zu machen. Und dieses System, wie ich schon sagte, lässt sich bei Armstrong ganz gut heute darstellen und es lohnt sich wirklich mit dem Wissen, um diesen Fall wieder mit den akuten Beispielen zu beschäftigen und sich immer neu die Frage vorzulegen, okay, was wir jetzt sehen, was wir jetzt mitbekommen, ist vielleicht wirklich nur die Spitze eines Eisbergs. Darunter gibt es garantiert, sage ich jetzt, garantiert bestimmte Ausprägungen von krimineller Energie und von bandenartiger Kriminalität.
Das finde ich das, was es so spannend macht, auch wenn wir jetzt nicht primär über den Fußball hier sprechen, aber mal sich mit einem solchen systematischen Fall, der jetzt eben einfach auch nach diesem Urteil abgeschlossen ist, für sich damit auseinanderzusetzen. Das hast du damit ganz schön beschrieben. Wie lange sitzt du denn eigentlich schon an diesem Thema Lance Armstrong? Also gerade die Zahl der Interviewten, hast du ja schon, du hast ja schon ein paar prominente Namen genannt. Wir haben jetzt auch ihre Stimmen auch schon zum Teil im Trailer gehört. Wie lange beschäftigst du dich schon mit diesem Thema?
Ja intensiver wirklich erst nachdem Armstrong zurückgekommen ist, was in der Geschichte, wie sie sich zugetragen hat, sicherlich sein allergrößter Fehler gewesen ist. Das hat er auch zugegeben in dem Interview mit Oprah Winfrey, in dem er ein Teilgeständnis abgegeben hat.
Und das war im Jahr 2009, glaube ich, dass er wieder angewiesen war.
Und diese Rückkehr hätte er sich ersparen können. Er war ja schon relativ erfolgreich gewesen und er war schon ziemlich alt. Es ist auch nach wie vor nicht ganz klar, was ihn da geritten hat. Aber das brachte ihn und die unaufgeklärten Dinge auch aus seiner Vergangenheit, die brachte die wieder nach oben. Und dann in der Zuspitzung ergab es sich eben, dass Floyd Landis, der eine Sperre bekommen hatte, zwei Jahre abgesessen hatte und dabei auch sehr arm geworden ist, weil er hat sein ganzes Geld in so eine vergebliche Verteidigung gesteckt. Der brauchte nun wieder Arbeit nach Ablauf der Sperre und der dachte, er könnte vielleicht bei Armstrongs Team anklopfen, weil er hatte ja nun nicht ausgepackt, er hatte nun nichts erzählt, also dicht gehalten und er brauchte einen Job als Radfahrer und da hat man in die Tür gewiesen. Und die Reaktion von Landis war dann als jemand, der gar nicht wusste, wie es dann nun für ihn weitergehen soll. Okay, dann macht er jetzt mal tabula rasa und packt aus. Gar nicht sehr strategisch, einfach sicherlich relativ impulsiv. Aber weil er sehr viel wusste und weil er bereit war, wirklich zu sagen, was er wusste, war das dann 2010, war das dann wirklich der entscheidende Punkt. Und das hat Armstrong völlig falsch eingeschätzt. Man kann ja froh sein, wenn der Landis einen Job gegeben hätte und sei es nur, um irgendwelche Reifen aufzupumpen oder so. Aber gut bezahlt, wäre das vielleicht gar nicht ins Rollen gekommen. Also kann man jetzt so nicht besprechen. Also die alternative Geschichte, die kann man sich ausmalen, aber die, man weiß es eben nicht.
Es ist schon einfach faszinierend, wie sehr es da manchmal an kleinen Zufällen hängt. Und jetzt haben wir eben schon gehört, wie sich das Ganze anhört und man kann es eben dazu noch als Buch lesen, was mich jetzt aber richtig umgehauen hat, Jürgen. Obwohl ich um deinen musikalischen Hintergrund wusste, war, dass jeder einzelne Ton, den wir auch gehört haben in diesem kurzen Trailer und in dem gesamten Hörbuch, aus deiner Feder stammt. Du hast auch noch alle Musik dazu komponiert.
Ja, also ich muss jetzt aus dem Nähkästchen plaudern. Ich sitze da nicht da und entwickle das in dem Moment komplett. Also einige Stücke habe ich wirklich für diese Situation dann geschrieben und produziert. Aber ich mache das schon sehr lange und habe deshalb auch ein ganz gutes Archiv.
Aber es ist alles von dir, das meinte ich damit.
Richtig, ja. Aber in einer Situation wie dieser ist es für mich etwas einfacher, weil ich dann wirklich auf ein sehr großes eigenes Archiv zurückgreifen kann und auch schauen kann. Also was würde denn von der Stimmung, zum Beispiel vom Charakter her, was würde reinpassen? Es handelt sich halt immer um Instrumentalmusik. Ich habe damit schon vor vielen Jahren angefangen. Ich setze das zum Beispiel auch hin und wieder in meinen eigenen Radioproduktionen ein oder auch, wenn ich Videos mache, meistens online Videos sind das ja nur, und kenne so ein bisschen jetzt so, habe das Gefühl entwickelt, wo funktioniert Musik, welche Art von Musik ist wohl stimmungsmäßig ganz passend. Ich glaube, man nennt das funktionale Musik, die soll sich ja unterordnen, die soll ja nicht unbedingt rausragen, das heißt also, wenn wir jetzt zum Beispiel darüber sprechen, ist das fast schon ein bisschen sehr aufmerksam, sehr viel Aufmerksamkeit darauf gegeben. Also die Idee ist eigentlich, dass es am Ende verschwindet in der ganzen Melauche und nicht unbedingt jetzt ja auf sich selber zeigt.
Das stimmt, aber wir sprechen ja hier mit dir und das geht ja auch ein bisschen über dich, wie du das gemacht hast, da fand ich es eben schon erwähnenswert, dass auch die Musik aus deiner Feder stammt.
Nein, ich möchte nicht sagen, ich möchte nicht drüber reden, im Gegenteil, das sind ja auch meine Kinder. Also wenn jemand sich die anhören möchte, das darf ich ja vielleicht hier noch erwähnen, also ich habe mir dann den Spaß gemacht. Es gibt eben nicht nur jetzt eine E-Book-Version und eine gedruckte Version und dieses Hörbuch, das man ja nicht ganz so klassisch als Hörbuch bezeichnen möchte, es gibt auch einen Soundtrack. Ich habe einfach ganz kack-frech die Musikstücke, die ich da eingesetzt habe, die habe ich einfach als, früher hätte man gesagt als Album, das heißt so eine ungefähre Länge, insgesamt von 30 Minuten, habe ich da auch bei Amazon reingestellt. Das heißt, finde ich wirklich jemand dafür interessiert. Der kann da zumindest auch seine Hörbeispiele abgreifen, denn man muss es ja nicht unbedingt sich jetzt zulegen oder so, aber man kann so ein bisschen durchhören, wie die einzelnen Musikstücke klingen und wie sie sich unterscheiden und so. Also das macht man alles, wenn man zu viel Zeit hat und zu viel Spaß an dem Ganzen hat, dann macht man auch noch sowas.
Naja, zu viel Zeit, das möchte ich ja leicht anzweifeln, denn das wäre so ein bisschen auch die Richtung meiner nächsten Frage gewesen. Du hast am Anfang gesagt, du bist derjenige, der sich mit den dreckigen Themen beschäftigt, also eben Korruption, Doping und so weiter. Und jetzt weiß ich ja selbst, weil ich auch immer mal wieder so die Fußspitze in diese Themen reinhalte, was für einen langen Atem man braucht, um da dabei zu bleiben, wie viel Zeit auch einfach nur dafür draufgeht, Sachverhalt zu verstehen und annähernd nachvollziehen zu können. Warum widmest du dich diesen komplexen Themen? Ist es nicht eigentlich hinderlich, wenn man mit anderen Beiträgen, du arbeitest ja als Journalist für verschiedene Medien, ein bisschen schneller Content-Inhalte, Artikel, Hörstücke produzieren könnte?
Nun habe ich das ja auch gemacht. Also ein Teil von dem, was man jetzt im Buch als kompaktes, umfangreiches Konzept nachholen kann, ist halt auch in der Arbeit, der täglichen Arbeit im Laufe der Jahre immer wieder eingeflossen. Nur halt viel kürzer, viel knapper, weil wir da, ob es nun in der Zeitung ist, da hat man auch nicht so viel Platz, oder ob es im Radio ist, da wird auch immer auf die Minute geschielt. Da ist man da ständig in der Not zu komprimieren, und das hat auch seine Vorteile, das will ich jetzt gar nicht beklagen. Aber da gehen so bestimmte Stimmungen und Nöancen auch verloren. Das heißt also, die Beschäftigung findet immer auf mehreren Ebenen, fast gleichzeitig statt, und in den meisten Fällen kommt ja auch gar kein Buch dabei herum. Ich hatte nur das Gefühl, dass gerade dieser Fall, mit dem ich mich eben theoretisch, könnte man sagen, seit 99, seitdem er seine erste Tour de France gefahren ist, habe ich angefangen, mich mit ihm zu beschäftigen. Und dann begleitet einen das auch sehr. Und es ist auch so ein bisschen eine Abarbeitung der eigenen Beschäftigung, der intensiven Beschäftigung mit so einem Thema. Weil ich glaube, es stecken tatsächlich so ein paar Gedanken von mir drin, die ich nicht formulieren konnte in der alltäglichen Arbeit. Und du hast gefragt, also komplex oder komplexe Themen. Ich glaube, so meine eigene persönliche Zuleigung zu bestimmten Themen und auch aus dem Sport besteht hauptsächlich nicht in der Abbildung von Dingen, die man heutzutage ja sowieso im Fernsehen dauernd sehen kann. Oder es gibt auf Twitter Ausschnitte in Videoform und so weiter. Das ist die Oberfläche, die ist inzwischen, ja, wird wahnsinnig gut abgebildet. Der klassische Sportjournalist ist früher sicherlich aufgerufen gewesen, das alleine zu leisten. Also eines meiner ersten Sportbücher ist ein Sportbuch über die Fußballweltmeisterschaft in Schweden 1958 gewesen. Und so wie dort geschrieben wurde, war das eben die Leistung. Niemand konnte das gesehen haben. Das lief kaum im Fernsehen und so weiter. Das war eine Rolle, wie das Journalismus eben lange gepflegt wurde. Und ich glaube, heute gehört sich das einfach, dass man einen anderen Anspruch entwickelt. Jeder wird das anders handhaben. Aber mein Anspruch ist der zu sagen, ich will hinter die Kulissen schauen, ich will erklären oder beschreiben, was dahinter passiert. Und da muss man dann auch auf viele verschiedene Details eingehen können und muss vielleicht auch so ein bisschen Bock haben, wie funktioniert sowas von der geschäftlichen Seite her, wie funktioniert das von der rechtlichen Seite, wie funktioniert das von der medizinischen Seite. Und ich bin trotzdem weit davon entfernt, in irgendeinem dieser Gebiete als Experte eingestuft zu werden. Ich glaube, die Kunst besteht dann in der Zusammenstellung oder in der Zusammenschau.
Und jetzt ist ja auch dieser Fall, Lance Armstrong, du hast es ja schon skizziert, ist wesentlich davon abhängig gewesen, von diesem, nennen wir es Zufall, das eben mit Floyd Landis ein entscheidender Kronzeuge, sage ich, ausgepackt hatte. Und das deprimiert mich ein bisschen, muss ich sagen. Wenn wir hier einen Fall von systematischem Doping haben, von dem dann viele gewusst haben, wie wir jetzt im Nachhinein auch bestätigt haben, und es dennoch nur durch diesen einen Switch tatsächlich dann so langsam peu a peu alles an die Oberfläche kam, das finde ich macht diesen Umgang mit dem Thema Doping besonders schwierig, weil man immer ganz viel im Trüben fischt und das Gefühl hat, die eigentlichen Themen, wenn es sie denn vielleicht gibt, man weiß es ja auch nicht, die kommen dann doch eher mal durch einen Zufall an die Oberfläche oder nicht. Was würdest du denn sagen, kann man jetzt von dem Fall Lance Armstrong und wie der verlaufen ist, generell für Berichterstattung im Doping-Missbrauchsverdacht im Sport und auch im Fußball ableiten?
Oh, das ist, wir hatten ja das Wort komplex schon mal, das ist auch schon wieder sehr komplex. Also ich versuche es mal so einfach wie möglich. Nummer eins, ja wir brauchen Wissenschaft, also das ganze System mit Blut- und Urin-Tests, das ist, erstmal kann man das nicht von der Hand weisen, aber wenn man sich anschaut, was für Resultate das produziert, kann man nur sagen, das ist Augenauswischerei. Im Bereich der Olympischen Spiele haben wir das ja jetzt über die letzten Jahre zum Beispiel konkret erlebt. Da gab es dann Nachtests von eingefrorenen Proben, weil man eben zu den Zeiten, in denen die Proben genommen wurden, hatte man teilweise diese Tests noch nicht. Und was stellt sich raus? Ganz viele, vor allen Dingen eben Topsportler, also Medaillengewinner, waren dann nach dem Stand der Wissenschaft von heute, waren sie eben gedoppt. Man kann jetzt ja nicht solche Dinge so bearbeiten und sagen, also acht Jahre später werden jetzt noch Medaillen aberkannt und werden Medaillen den Leuten zuerkannt, die nicht erwischt worden sind. Das ist so eine Erkenntnis, das ist ganz schwierig. Das andere ist, dass natürlich, wenn es um die Bestrafung von Leuten geht, die dopen, die Frage natürlich ist, nach welchen Rechtskriterien geht man davor? Und nicht nur nach welchen in einzelnen Ländern. Also Deutschland hat eben inzwischen ja auch ein Dopinggesetz, aber die wenigsten Länder haben das überhaupt. Und selbst da, wo es Dopinggesetze nicht gibt, gibt es Betrugsgesetzgebung. Nach welchen Kriterien würde das also juristisch abgehandelt? Und der Sport hat seine eigene Sportgerichtsbarkeit entwickelt im Laufe der Jahre und da geht man sehr, sehr vorsichtig mit den aufgebrachten Fällen um. Weil man auch weiß, jede Bestrafung, also zum Beispiel eine Sperre von zwei Jahren oder im Wiederholungsfall ja auch länger, das sind ja fast berufsverbotet. Da können ja Menschen dann gar nicht mehr ihrer Arbeit nachgehen. Das heißt, wir kommen auf eine ganz, ganz difficile Weise mit Dingen in Berührung, die man eben alle nicht so einfach beantworten kann. Klar, der moralische Impetus ist die, und da bin ich auch ganz schlicht gestrickt. Es handelt sich um Betrug. Da werden minimum die Gegner betrogen, die nicht gedobt waren, wobei ich schätze mal, das sind vielleicht nur die Hälfte. Dann wird jeder betrogen, der dort irgendeine Prämie ausgelobt hat und so weiter. Es wird jeder Sponsor betrogen, der geglaubt haben könnte, ja es geht alles normal zu. Und natürlich wird auch die ganze Öffentlichkeit betrogen, die ja nun glaubt, ja also wir haben da im Fußball wieviel Regeln haben wir da? Wir haben ja sehr wenig Regeln, 17 oder 18 Fußballregeln. Aber die Regeln, nach denen alle spielen und alle von allen akzeptiert werden, ja dann muss das ja da fair zugehen. Und das ist eben nicht der Fall. Das ist ein ständiger Prozess, bei dem Leute versuchen, diese Regeln irgendwie auszuhebeln oder zu umgehen. Also der Betrug an der Öffentlichkeit. Nicht unbedingt quantifizierbar, aber der ist natürlich ein besonders starkes Element. Und wenn man mit dieser Sicht, wie ich sie da entwickelt habe, da ja daran geht, kommt man vielleicht an einen ganz, ganz schwierigen Punkt, das nach dem Motto, ja dann sollte ich ja vielleicht aufhören, mich mit Sport zu beschäftigen oder mich für Sport zu begeistern. Und das muss dann auch wieder jeder für sich lösen. Ich selber habe einen einfachen Weg gefunden. Da ich mich beruflich damit beschäftige, bleibe ich also dran. Wenn ich jetzt nur mich privat damit beschäftigen würde, würde ich vielleicht längst frustriert sagen, nee also Sport, danke, das reicht mir, da will ich nichts mehr mit zu tun haben.
Ja und das ist ja auch das Dilemma, in dem jeder Einzelne steckt. Je mehr er sich mit solchen Themen beschäftigt und ja vielleicht auch der Grund dafür, warum man als Journalist, egal ob man etwas aufdeckt oder etwas oder eine kritische Frage nicht stellt, ein bisschen ist man immer der Buhmann und ist ein ganz schwieriges Spannungsfeld. Und so ganz sehe ich auch zum Beispiel jetzt auf den Fußball bezogen, noch nicht wo sich etwas zu mehr Transparenz hin verändern sollte. Der Fußball hat sich so seine eigene Welt geschaffen, in der Doping vermeintlich gar keine Rolle spielt, in der es aber auch keine wirkliche Kontrolle gibt, auch wenn der Fußball das immer behauptet. Aber das kann man sehr schnell nachweisen, dass das nicht so, dass wenn wir schon bei der VADA sehen, bei olympischen Spitzensportlern, dass da viel dann erst im Nachhinein aufgedeckt wird, dann ist es beim Fußball noch um die Komponente erweitert, dass es auch nicht sehr wahrscheinlich ist, kontrolliert zu werden in bestimmten Phasen der Saison und so weiter. Und dennoch ist man als jemand, der an diesem Thema kritisch dranbleiben möchte, eben immer in der Situation, dass es fast keine Fakten dazu gibt und dass man darauf angewiesen ist, dass irgendwann dieses Kartell des Schweigens, was im Sport sich etabliert hat, von irgendjemandem durchbrochen wird und sich dann vielleicht etwas verändert. Aber immer nur retrospektiv.
Ja, und also das hatte ich jetzt vergessen anzusprechen. Ich denke, wir als Journalisten haben es da sehr schwer, weil wir haben nicht solche Mittel, um Leute dazu zu bringen, uns zu erzählen, was sie wissen. Wir können da nur hoffen, dass jemand irgendwann aus welchen Gründen auch immer auspackt oder dass er Dinge anonym jemandem zuspielt. Das passiert ja auch hin und wieder. Die Polizei und die Staatsanwaltschaften, die sind ja nicht jetzt hauptsächlich dafür da, die Dopa zu finden. Die haben auch noch andere Verbrecher zu finden. Also es ist zwar schön, dass es die gibt. Und die haben Mittel zur Verfügung, die Journalisten nicht haben. Hausdurchsuchungen, zum Beispiel, wenn Richter das genehmigen. Und sie können Leute unter Eid zu aussagen zwingen. Das haben wir Journalisten nicht. Ich glaube, einer der am wenigsten gut behandelten Bereiche in diesem Doping-Komplex, obwohl wir haben aufgrund der DDR-Geschichte mit dem Doping dort und der berühmten Freiburger Ärzte-Seilschaft, haben wir natürlich auch so ein paar Figuren. Aber ich würde immer gerne auf diese Leute aufmerksam machen, auf Mediziner zum Beispiel, weil die kommen mit der billigsten Ausrede davon, weil die haben das Privileg, also eine Schweigepflicht über ihre Patienten, müssen sie keine Auskunft geben und können sich dahinter verschanzen und tun das auch nach Kräften. Und haben inzwischen auch ganz schnell einen Anwalt zur Hand, wenn man also versucht, sie dazu zu bringen, doch mal was zu erzählen, weil sie dann Sorge haben, dass sie sich vielleicht verplappern könnten oder so. Also so einen Fall habe ich eben im Rahmen der Beschäftigung mit Tyler Hamilton erlebt. Und da wäre jetzt so mal mein Kummer. Aber auch, also ich habe das auch erlebt, ich war bei der Firma Track in Wisconsin und habe dort miterlebt, wie man dort also mit der eigenen Geschichte umgeht und so tut, als hätte Armstrong diese Firma an der Nase rumgeführt und sie seien auch Opfer dieser Durchtriebenheit dieses Sportlers. Auch das sind Leute, denen man eigentlich extrem auf die Finger klopfen müsste. Aber die sind ja Teil des Finanzsystems. Also wer soll denen jetzt sagen, macht mal die Hosen runter, weil wenn die alle wegbleiben, ist der kommerzielle Sport ja kaum noch zu finanzieren.
Ja und es bleibt dieses ewige Wandeln zwischen moralischem und juristischem Recht und richtig und falsch, wo ja sowieso jeder schon mal seine Koordinaten im moralischen Bereich anders ausgerichtet hat. Das ist ja etwas Subjektives und wo das juristische Argument immer das Entscheidende bleiben sollte und das greift aber in vielen Fällen nicht. Das ist ja vorher auch schon angedeutet mit der Rechtslage. Das hat man zum Beispiel im Umgang mit den Football-Leaks auch sehr häufig. Viele der Mannschaften sind juristisch legal, moralisch, aber in meinem Koordinatensystem nicht top. Und dann ist aber die Frage, wie möchte man das bewerten? Mit Freiburg hast du ja auch schon ein interessantes Beispiel genannt. Das ist so zum Beispiel einer der Fälle, wo ich immer wieder in der, ich sage jetzt mal täglichen Arbeit am Rasenfunk dran denke. Immer nämlich, wenn ich Freiburg für die Laufleistung lobe, das ist eine der Mannschaften, die am meisten läuft in der Bundesliga, dann fällt mir immer bei jeder zweiten Erwähnung ein, ja in der Stadt, in der es halt früher dieses inzwischen nachgewiesene systematische Doping von der Universitätsklinik aus gab. Und man kann das nicht immer dazu sagen, es wäre auch falsch von der Vergangenheit darauf zu schließen, dass jetzt definitiv da was faul sein müsste. Da befindet man sich in einem ganz unguten Fahrwasser. Und dennoch liegt es mir manchmal auf der Zunge, diesen Fakt noch mitzuliefern für den Hinterkopf der Hörerinnen und Hörer. Wobei ich ja eine Unterstellung davor nehme, für die ich keinerlei Belege hätte und die auch völlig falsch sein kann. Aber das ist so ein klassisches Dilemma, wo es quasi auch im Rasenfunk immer unausgesprochen mitschwingt. Wenn man weiß, um so Fälle, hat man dann sogar eine orts- und personengebundene Kooperation zwischen dem Verein und gewissen Medizinern gehabt, die jetzt da auch nichts mehr zu sagen haben. Das hat aber irgendwie auch einen Wert für die gegenwärtige Berichterstattung.
Und es ist so vieles auch nicht wirklich endgültig erforscht. Also zum Beispiel gibt es Beispiele aus der Leichtathletik, wo so ein Mann wie Justin Gatlin, der also zweimal bestraft worden ist, und der kommt nach der zweiten Strafe zurück und läuft schneller denn je und ist so alt, das haben jetzt auch Sportwissenschaftler mal versucht, anhand vergleichbarer Daten, also wie alt ist eigentlich jemand, wenn er die eigene Leistungsspitze erreicht, der ist weit übersatzalter hinaus gewesen, völlig unerklärlich, aber es kann zum Beispiel sein, dass wenn man sich schon jung gut dobt und hoffentlich nicht erwischt wird dann, dass man eine Anreicherung hinbekommt, also die Fähigkeit zu regenerieren oder die Fähigkeit, auch die Muskulatur stärker belasten zu können und so weiter, dass das alles auch noch einen kumulativen Effekt hat. Das ist alles bisher überhaupt nicht richtig klar, das kommt einem so vor, als ob die Leute, die versuchen, die Dopa zu erwischen, als ob die wirklich so mit, gab es noch so ein Spiel, glaube ich Kinderpost oder so, als ob die mit solchen Dingen spielen, die zwar der Realität irgendwie nachgebildet sind, aber trotzdem keine richtigen Waffen sind. Und da fällt mir aber noch was anderes auf, wenn du Freiburg und die Bundesliga sagst. Freiburg hat 17 Gegner in der ersten Liga. Wenn die sagen würden, uns fällt was auf, können wir das nicht mal besser untersuchen, hätte man ja schon eine Pressure Group zusammen. Aber ich glaube, die Bundesliga dokumentiert hier auch, dass sie da kein Interesse daran haben. Man lebt halt mit dem, wie es so ist.
Aus welchen Motiven auch immer.
Und es gibt ja die drei Affen, die also als Symbolbild für nicht sehen, nicht hören, nicht reden, das wird ja in vielen Bereichen in der Gesellschaft pro-praktiziert. Und der Sport ist ja natürlich da auch nicht anders.
Ja, und du hast natürlich auch mit Justin Gatlin schon die Figur genannt, an der man auch festmachen kann, wie folgenschwer und gleichzeitig auch jahresköpfig eine gute und kritische investigative Berichterstattung sein kann. Justin Gatlin wurde dann bei der Weltmeisterschaft, glaube ich, wo er dann auch Usain Bolt geschlagen hat. Justin Gatlin wurde vom Publikum ausgeboot, aus nachvollziehbaren Gründen. Usain Bolt wurde gefeiert, der ein völlig sauberer Sportler sein kann. Aber gleichzeitig hatten wir bei den Sprintern Jamaikas schon einige Dopingfälle. Und er wäre dann fast, kann man schon sagen, fast wäre er die Ausnahme, wenn er nicht gedopt wäre. Und das zeigt ja auch, wie irre das eigentlich ist bei dem einen. Der eine bekommt dann den ganzen Unmut der Fans auch nach seinem Sieg an diesem Abend zu spüren. Der andere wird gefeiert, weil er, ich sage jetzt einfach mal in Anführungszeichen, vielleicht noch mit sauberer Weste dasteht. Das zeigt schon, in welchem Spannungsband man sich da bewegt. Aber Jürgen, ich möchte jetzt nicht wieder mit so einer negativen Note aus einer Sendung mit dir rausgehen. Ich glaube, mich zu erinnern, dass es damals beim FIFA-Prozess auch schon so war, dass wir uns gegenseitig in Angriffen hatten.
Na ja, aber da gab es zumindest, wir haben ja auch darüber gesprochen, da ist ja noch immer nicht jeder bestraft worden, aber einige sind ja schon bestraft worden. Da gab es ja zumindest eine Reaktion aus dem amerikanischen Justizwesen, die gesagt haben, ihr kommt jetzt ein paar Jahre ins Gefängnis. Das heißt, auf eine gewisse Weise endet das dann ja doch auf einer positiven Note. Also die Leute wurden, man hat ihnen entweder bewiesen, was sie gemacht haben, oder sie haben gestanden und die Gesellschaft reagiert in dem Fall mit Gefängnis. Das finde ich jetzt nicht unbedingt eine gute Überleitung hier zu dem, was du sagen wolltest. Ich wollte nur sagen, für mich wäre das schon wieder eine positive Note am Ende, wenn man das Gefühl hat, ja, Leute werden auch hinreichend bestraft. Und erstmal egal, ob das dann einen Effekt hat auf die nächste Generation, dass es also eine Abschreckung möglich macht. Ich bin da nicht so ein Fan von dieser Theorie, aber ich bin ein Fan von diesem Gedanken, okay, du hast Mist gebaut, jetzt musst du zur Rechenschaft gezogen werden können. Und das ist die Quittung. Das ist die Rechnung, die du jetzt bezahlen musst. Und das kann ich also durchaus immer auch als positiv empfinden. Aber da wir ja zusammen im Rasenfunk sind und das ist dein Baby, deine Emotionen und deine Sentiments sind wichtiger jetzt als meine.
Quatsch, also zum einen glaube ich, dass das bei der großen Sendung, beim Tribünengespräch so war, dass wir uns dann im Nachhinein so ein bisschen, als wir dann auch herausgearbeitet hatten, welche juristische Handhabe man eigentlich hat bei einem in der FIFA situierten, gemeinnützigen, in Anführungszeichen, Verband. Da kann ich mich noch erinnern, dass dieser Part des Tribünengesprächs, der hat mich frustriert. Aber ich wollte ja eigentlich darauf hinweisen, dass es von dir in ähnlicher Form ja bald noch mehr zu hören gibt und dann mal kein dreckiges Thema, hoffe ich doch zumindest.
Nein. Also, ich glaube, du hast ja erst kein Stichwort gesagt, aber ich glaube, ich weiß, um was es dir jetzt gegangen ist. Also es gibt dann jetzt schon in ein paar Wochen das nächste Buch und das ist über die Karriere von Dirk Nowitzki und das hat den Titel So weit, Punkt, So gut, Punkt, ist doppelt bis drei mehrdeutig gedacht, weil wir haben hier den Fall von jemanden, der kommt aus der deutschen Provinz und entwickelt sich so einem absoluten Weltstar und an dem ist aber auch rein gar nichts auszusetzen, außer dass man als Journalist sich immer gerne gewünscht hätte, dass er ein bisschen mehr erzählt, von innen heraus. Aber er ist eben nicht der Typ, der redet nicht gerne über sich selbst oder wenn, dann eben auf eine sehr verhaltene Art und Weise, das kann man akzeptieren. Und das ist ein Versuch, dieses Buch, also diesen Bogen, der sich da in seiner Karriere niedergeschlagen hat, den nachzuzeichnen und da kann man dann nur sagen, das ist eigentlich eine Verbeugung vor einer ungewöhnlichen, vor einem ungewöhnlichen Menschen und einer ungewöhnlichen Karriere und das ist, abgesehen von vielleicht der ein oder anderen Nuance, das ist wirklich ganz positiv zu verstehen.
Genau, und wird es ja auch wieder in so einer Sonic Stories, also in einer Radio-Feature-Version, sage ich jetzt mal, auch noch mal geben?
Ja, allerdings nicht gleich, weil das hat jetzt vom Timing nicht geklappt, der Mann wird ja wahrscheinlich jetzt seine Karriere beenden und ich musste erstmal gucken, dass ich das Manuskript für die gedruckte Ausgabe hinbekomme, weil ja auch der Buchmarkt auch so ähnlich funktioniert. Also die meisten Menschen interessieren sich ja nicht für Hörbücher, die wollen ja, wenn sie ein Buch haben wollen, wollen es ja doch eher gedruckt haben, das soll ins Regal, das ist ja auch schön. Das ist das eine und das andere, es gibt auch nicht ganz so viel Interviewmaterial oder anderes Material im Laufe der Zeit von mir eingesammelt, es gibt auch einige wichtige Interviews, aber dort habe ich erstmal beschlossen, es ist erstmal wichtig, dass es gedruckt gut rauskommt und in dem Fall hatte ich auch das Glück, dass ich einen kleinen Verlag in Hildesheim gefunden habe, der mir auch einen Teil dieser Arbeit gut abnimmt, die man ja als Autor auch zu schätzen weiß, also Lektorat und die ganze Verwaltung und das Marketing und so weiter. Und das ist der ART-Verlag in Hildesheim und das Buch kann man schon vorbestellen, wenn ich das noch sagen darf, aber fertig sein wird es wohl genau zu dem Termin, wo Dirk Nowitzki jetzt nächsten Monat in Dallas eine große Pressekonferenz machen wird. Er hat nicht gesagt, was er da sagen wird, aber ich fände alles andere als, ja, tschüss, das ist jetzt eine große Überraschung, weil so richtig gut spielt er nicht mehr.
Aber gab es nicht noch einen Spieler, der jetzt zu den Maps gewechselt ist und der Dirk Nowitzki gebeten hat, noch ein Jahr unter ihm oder mit ihm von ihm lernen zu dürfen? Ich habe den Namen gerade vergessen.
Portzingis, ja, genau. Ja, ich kann mir einfach nicht ausmalen, wenn man sich anschaut, wie trainieren NBA-Profis. Das ist ja jetzt auch wieder sehr individuell. Jeder trainiert ein bisschen für sich selber oder geht selbst für sich alleine in die Fitnessräume. Klar kann man davon profitieren, dass ein erfahrener Spieler einem was beibringt. Aber dazu muss der auch nicht auf dem Platz stehen. Wir haben das in der NBA auch jetzt sehr stark. Das ehemalige grandiose Typen, speziell auch für die langen Spieler, abgestellt werden, die die sogenannten Center oder Power-Forwards dann auch einzeln sich vorknüpfen. Und das könnte Dirk Nowitzki auch machen, wenn er als Assistenz-Trainer bei den Mavericks dabei wäre und vielleicht sogar noch einfacher, weil dann könnte er sich wirklich darum kümmern und müsste sich nicht selber noch irre fit halten oder so. Also ich glaube nicht, dass man jemanden wie Dirk Nowitzki, der eh jetzt nur noch als Ersatzspieler fünf bis sechs Minuten auf den Platz kommt, dass das eine psychologisch unglaublich starke Auswirkung auf den jungen Spieler, der im Moment verletzt ist, aber sicherlich bald wieder fit ist, auf den haben wird. Ich glaube, wenn die im Training miteinander umgehen und er es ja akzeptiert, den Älteren als den großen Fundus für Technik und auch für Strategie vom Spiel und so, das wäre genauso gut. Und das ist das, was man auch auf Dallas immer gehört hat. Also der kann jederzeit da einen Job haben, wenn er aufhört. Die wollen den nicht loswerden, die wollen ihn halten. Der ist ja eine Vorzeigefigur auch in Dallas und einer der besten Basketballer aller Zeiten, unbestritten und in Dallas eben eine Riesennummer.
Also Dirk Nowitzki, soweit so gut. Jetzt haben wir sogar noch über NBA gesprochen. Allerletzte und wichtigste Frage aber, Jürgen, wo kann man das Buch Nichts als die Wahrheit der Fall Lance Armstrong oder eben auch die, ich nenne sie jetzt Hörbuchversion, davon denn erwerben?
Ja, das ist wahrscheinlich am einfachsten im Netz bei all den Anbietern, die man da hat. Also es ist nicht nur Amazon, aber Amazon ist glaube ich ziemlich begierig, sich die Sachen anzubieten. Aber man kann auch in ein normales Buchgeschäft gehen, dann müsste man es halt bestellen, weil da liegt es nicht vor, aber das wird dann innerhalb kürzester Zeit zugestellt und das kostet auch außer der Mühe, ins Buchgeschäft zu gehen, kostet das nichts extra. Also ich kann das nur empfehlen. Das Hörbuch kriegt man nur als Stream. Es wird es vielleicht mal irgendwann, wenn ich mir das so gönne, auch noch als CD geben, aber ich glaube nicht, dass jemand wirklich jetzt darauf warten sollte.
Nein, lieber jetzt. Okay, also ihr werdet...
Bei dem Nowitzki-Buch, also garantiert, das wird bestimmt in bestimmten Buchläden auch ganz gut platziert werden, weil ich glaube, der Nowitzki ist ja eine große Nummer und wird respektiert. Und ich glaube auch, dass es Menschen geben wird, die das interessiert.
Das wollen wir doch sehr hoffen. Jürgen, vielen, vielen Dank. Man kann alle Informationen zu dem, was wir jetzt gerade gesprochen haben, auch noch auf der Seite sonicsstories.com nachschlagen. Sonics mit X wie Xaver in der Mitte. Ich werde es auch nochmal natürlich verlinken. Ihr könnt Jürgen auf Twitter folgen. Ad American Arena heißt er da und freut sich sicherlich sehr über Feedback. Ich hoffe, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, dass ihr jetzt diesen kurzen Ausflug mal aus dem Fußball heraus verzeiht. Ich finde das Thema aber sehr, sehr spannend. Und wir alle schätzen Jürgen und hören auch einfach seine Stimme gern zu. Das nächste Mal lasse ich mir von dir Kochbuchrezepte vorlesen. Wahrscheinlich mögen das die Hörerinnen und Hörer dann auch. Danke, dass du mal wieder mit dabei warst.
Ich bedanke mich sehr.
Und euch, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, danke für eure Aufmerksamkeit. Das war Kurzpass Nummer 122. Es wartet in der Nacht auf Montag die nächste Schlusskonferenz auf euch. Und es ist gerade auch ein neues Tribünengespräch erschienen zu Fußballfilmen. Mal ein ganz anderes Thema. Führt euch das doch gerne mal zu Gemüte, so ihr das denn noch nicht getan habt. Und dann freue ich mich auch über Feedback unter mitmachen.rasenfunk.de. Bis zum nächsten Mal. Machts gut.